[SPEAKER_00]: Je vous remercie grandement pour l'occasion de vous présenter le travail, notre travail de richesse, qui porta, s'il l'était, la qualité des institutions sur la transformation culturelle en Afrique tchadienne, les rôles du patriarcat latin.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le travail a été mené par Mme Stavro Valentin et Mme Idrissa Oudaho,
[SPEAKER_00]: Débattement des laboratoires du CDS, Débattement de l'économie de l'université Thomas Sankara et Burkina Faso.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alors, le travail est structuré en cinq grands points.
[SPEAKER_00]: Premièrement, nous présentons le contexte des problématiques sur les météorologiques et l'hypothèse, la bourse méthodologique, les résultats et les discussions, et enfin, la conclusion et l'implication de politiques économiques.
[SPEAKER_00]: Next.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ok.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pour démarrer, on définit la transformation budgétaire selon M. Seminar et O.D.
[SPEAKER_00]: 2011 comme une réallocation des activités des partenaires de production des secteurs affaires de productivité vers les secteurs à plus forte valeur ajoutée.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est cette transformation budgétaire qui est importante pour les pays d'affaires citoyennes où on constate une réallocation
[SPEAKER_00]: et l'efficacité des ressources.
[SPEAKER_00]: Selon les auteurs comme Kuznet en 1979, l'Afrique vit la même possibilité de réaliser une croissance sous le thème du privé réel par habitant sans une transformation culturelle là profonde.
[SPEAKER_00]: De même, Togaro en 1980 affirme que l'assemblée de productivité va aller sur la diversification économique et l'aide
[SPEAKER_00]: le mouvement de cartel de main-d'oeuvre de l'année 2020, le secteur manufacturier est indispensable pour la croissance et le développement du lard en Afrique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ainsi, la Sécurité de Développement Économique et le Command de Sahel, qui existe pour la production et la répartition de l'emploi, dans le but d'accroître
[SPEAKER_00]: la meilleure performance économique selon Harold Hall en 2016.
[SPEAKER_00]: Les statistiques montrent que la production manufacturière mondiale à l'économie hausse de 7,2% en 2021, mais a été réduite de 0,5% dans les pays les moins avancés selon les données de l'économie de 2022.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et même en Afrique subsaharienne, la part de valeur adulte manufacturière a passé de
[SPEAKER_00]: 10,15% des lignes d'Infa à 11,37% des lignes de Syriens, selon les données de la Banque mondiale.
[SPEAKER_00]: De même, on constate pour la même donnée que 48 pays d'Afrique subsaharienne appartiennent à la moitié inférieure des pays placés selon le prix, le faible niveau de pollution.
[SPEAKER_00]: Également, selon les données de Transparency International, la moitié des pays d'Afrique subsaharienne sont en espoir inférieurs à 50% du niveau de production.
[SPEAKER_00]: Au niveau du capital humain, le constat est que oui, c'est dit, les enfants en âge fréquenté sont scolarisés et 94% de ces enfants atteignent la cinquième année.
[SPEAKER_00]: Du point de vue théorique,
[SPEAKER_00]: on trouve un lien entre la qualité des institutions et la transformation culturelle en Afrique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Ainsi, Adam Smith montre que le commerce et la manufacturelle ne peuvent poster dans un état où l'adoption n'est pas réglée de justice, où le droit de propriété n'est pas garanti.
[SPEAKER_00]: De même, les états-levels institutionnalistes, notamment l'an 2000-1941, définissent la qualité des institutions comme des normes humainement conçues pour
[SPEAKER_00]: permettent l'interaction des états usinaires.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dans le même sens, à ce moment-là, qui distingue les institutions politiques des institutions économiques, et même les institutions inclusives des institutions extracives, montre que les institutions sont nécessaires pour le développement économique et social en Afrique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Du point de vue empirique, le terme est hors de l'initiative, montre que les bonnes institutions sont
[SPEAKER_00]: important pour le niveau d'industrialisation en Afrique sub-saharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alors que Mansha et Allah et Godanon et Al-Denis Sahela constatent que son effet sur la performance industrielle n'est pas significatif.
[SPEAKER_00]: Dans le même sens, l'Union Habitat-Denis-Tel montre que la croissance et le développement modèles dépendent à la fois de l'engouement institutionnel et de la disponibilité
[SPEAKER_00]: des ressources humaines appropriées, d'où notre question de s'interroger sur le rôle de capital humain.
[SPEAKER_00]: La question globale de notre travail est quel est l'effet de l'euro de capital humain dans l'effet de la qualité des institutions sur la transformation culturelle en Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: De façon spécifique, il s'agit de donner à la force spécifique des institutions qui améliorent la transformation culturelle en Afrique.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et encore, quels sont les effets interactifs de la qualité des institutions sur le capital humain en Afrique subsaharienne ?
[SPEAKER_00]: L'objectif global est d'analyser le rôle du capital humain dans l'effet de la qualité des institutions sur la transparence culturelle en Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: De façon spécifique, il s'agit d'identifier les formes spécifiques des institutions qui améliorent la transparence culturelle en Afrique subsaharienne et d'analyser les effets interactifs de la qualité des institutions
[SPEAKER_00]: et du capital qui vient aussi de la transformation culturelle en Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et c'est là que nous prenons les hypothèses suivantes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le contrôle de production, l'efficacité du gouvernement et la qualité de régulation améliorent la transformation culturelle en Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: La qualité institutionnelle a un effet synergique avec le capital qui vient dans l'amélioration des effets de la transformation culturelle en Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le modèle là, nous utilisons le modèle là
[SPEAKER_00]: Entre celles se basent les modèles de Toulouse de la présence androgène de Romain 86.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le modèle ambiguïde se présente comme ci.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous présentons d'abord les états directs, ensuite les états indirects.
[SPEAKER_00]: En guise de moteur d'estimation, nous utilisons des moteurs de moment généralisés en système.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous avons fait des tests préliminaires de multipollinéarité.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous obtenons qu'il est absent de multipollinéarité.
[SPEAKER_00]: Il y a dépendance interindividuelle et toutes les variables sont stationnaires dans le niveau.
[SPEAKER_00]: Le deuxième problème de la part de la Banque mondiale de 2024,
[SPEAKER_00]: qui couvrent une période de 2000 à 2024, c'est-à-dire les 30 pays d'Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: Les estimations nous permettent d'obtenir les résultats suivants.
[SPEAKER_00]: La qualité des institutions, du point de vue global, a un effet positif et significatif à 1% sur la transformation publique en Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: De même, si on prend des façons désagrégées, les éducateurs, ils n'obtenaient que le contrôle des pollutions, l'efficacité des gouvernances et la qualité des régulations sans l'apport spécifique des institutions qui améliorent la qualité de la transformation culturelle dans le pays d'Afrique du Sud-Saharien.
[SPEAKER_00]: Également, l'état des droits et la voie des responsabilités
[SPEAKER_00]: Un effet positif et significatif, c'est la transformation culturelle au seuil des 5%.
[SPEAKER_00]: Et enfin, la stabilité politique influence positivement et significativement la transformation culturelle au seuil des 10%.
[SPEAKER_00]: Cela montre l'importance des qualités des étudiants dans nos pays d'Afrique subsaharienne pour améliorer la transformation culturelle.
[SPEAKER_00]: L'enregistrement pour le droit à l'essai des tortures de l'OAD 2019
[SPEAKER_00]: mais va dans le sens contraire avec l'Akmanisah et Allah des milliers de siècles.
[SPEAKER_00]: Pour analyser l'effet interactif, nous trouvons que l'interaction entre le capital humain et la qualité des investissements affecte positivement et significativement la qualité de la transformation culturelle dans le pays d'Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: En guise de conclusion,
[SPEAKER_00]: L'objectif était d'analyser les rôles du capital humain dans l'étude des qualités des institutions sur la transformation culturelle en Afrique sub-saharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous obtenons le résultat suivant.
[SPEAKER_00]: Une amélioration de la qualité des institutions améliore la transformation culturelle dans la région d'Afrique sub-saharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: Plus spécifiquement, l'amélioration de la contrôle de corruption, l'efficacité des gouvernances et la qualité des évidations
[SPEAKER_00]: sont les forces spécifiques des institutions qui améliorent la transformation culturelle dans nos pays d'Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: En outre, les capitales humaines servent de levier pour améliorer les effets de la qualité des institutions sur la transformation culturelle en Afrique subsaharienne.
[SPEAKER_00]: C'est du confinement non-disposalisé de départ.
[SPEAKER_00]: En termes d'implications économiques, nous recommandons de décider à améliorer à
[SPEAKER_00]: Mettre en place des réformes institutionnelles efficaces en vue de lutter efficacement contre la corruption, apporter la transparence dans la gestion des affaires publiques et une meilleure régulation de la marché.
[SPEAKER_00]: Également, nous décidérions de réorienter le système éducatif vers les formations les plus pointilles qui sont favorables à l'innovation, donc à la transformation spirituelle.
[SPEAKER_00]: Également, la mise en place des infrastructures éducatives et des formations de qualité.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nous sommes au terme de notre présentation.
[SPEAKER_00]: Je vous remercie pour votre attention.